ich verstehe die euphorie denn ich frage
mich sind sie zu hause auch so
erleichtert und begeistert wie ich es
ist vollbracht freunde in einer
schmerzhaften nächtlichen steiß geburt
ist ein kleines klimapaket auf die welt
gekommen mutter und paket sind wohlauf
soll ich ihnen sagen
und ich das mal ganz ehrlich und ohne
ironie der show anteil in der deutschen
politik wird mir persönlich langsam
deutlich zu hoch wenn man jahrelang an
einem so wichtigen thema wie klima rumpf
riegelt warum zum teufel muss dann die
entscheidende sitzung an einem
donnerstag um 22 uhr anfangen was soll
das theater nun werden die fragen was
haben wir da die vielen stunden getan
und die vielen stunden schon vorher ja
genau das wäre meine frage gewesen
was habt ihr eigentlich getan die vielen
stunden ein wildes durcheinander von
förderprogrammen verrührt mit dem
üblichen schuss klientel politik ganz
viel zuckerbrot plus mikroskopisch
kleine peitsche jetzt bauen wir einen
nationalen emissionshandel für verkehr
und gebäude auf was jahre dauern wird
die zeit nehmen bei uns und starten bei
gerade mal zehn euro pro tonne co2
obwohl alle forscher sagen 50 bis 100
euro wären nötig das ist ein tolles
signal an die 270.000 menschen die heute
allein in berlin für echten klimaschutz
auf die straße gegangen sind
das ist mal bei dem kam das paket gar
nicht gut an das gros klima kabinett
diese gottverdammte helden truppe meine
damen und herren
sagt trotzdem sie haben einen
wasserdichten plan für mich ist das
mutloser klimaschutz für zu viel geld 54
milliarden bis 2023 und im gegensatz zur
schweiz wo allen bürgern was
zurückgegeben wird sind es bei uns
eigentlich nur die pendler die bald
entlastet werden aber immerhin wir haben
endlich mal neue ziele aufgeschrieben
und ich verstehe auch diejenigen die
sagen ja wer soll ich das denn glauben
dass ihr das das nächste mal wirklich
schafft und wir glauben da nicht so
richtig daran denn ihr habt uns dass wir
schon 2020 gesagt also 2020 habt ihr uns
das noch nicht gesagt
weil das vom raum zeit kontinuum nicht
geht aber 2007 habt ihr schon mal gesagt
was diesmal aber ganz anders ist ab
jetzt schneiden sie sich an will das
tolle klima kabinett sich einmal im jahr
treffen und gucken ob sie ihre
klimaziele erreichen und wenn nicht dann
überlegt man sich was sie lachen aber
das steht ja leider drin
heute redet frau merkel von dem was
zitat politisch möglich ist neulich im
bundestag war klimaschutz noch die
menschheitsaufgabe ich dachte wir müssen
unseren kindern einen bewohnbaren
planeten hinterlassen
wir wollen unseren kindern eine
wettbewerbsfähige wirtschaft in
deutschland hinterlassen richte ich mein
fehler
mein fehler ja und ich fürchte da
spricht der kleine paul einigen bürgern
aus der seele
bürgern die auch finden man soll das mit
dem klimaschutz mal bitte nicht
übertreiben
bäte nicht auch weil politiker in diesem
land seit den 90ern über klima reden
ohne wirklich zu handeln ich habe sich
einfach nur was wünschen ist aber in
wirklichkeit keine politik deswegen
haben wir ja heute gerade mal 83.000
echte e autos auf unseren straßen hier
merkel 2011 wir wollen gerne dass bis
2020 eine million elektrofahrzeuge auf
unseren straßen im einsatz sind
außerdem wollen wir ein pony
und dass barbie traumhaus es ist doch es
ist doch alles nur noch albern ernsthaft
jetzt natürlich wird echter klimaschutz
auch wehtun
warum spricht dass immer noch keiner von
denen aus und der klimaschutz nicht
wehtun
klimaschutz muss anders als hier einige
redner dargestellt haben muss freude
verbreiten dem klimaschutz zu einem
echten mitmach projekt machen das ist
kein quell kam klima als ein mitmach
projekt alle müssen spaß an der sache
haben
ein bisschen spaß muss
ja ich habe vorher mit mir gewettet ob
sie mit klatschen sie haben verloren
fanfaren weltuntergang
die haben panische angst vor uns wählern
deswegen so gut wie keine verbote im
klimapaket außer für neue ölheizung ab
2026 und ohne ende luftbuchung nehmen
wir als beispiel mal einen minister der
in dieser show meiner meinung nach viel
zu selten vorkommt an die steuern an die
schau ist mit einem sagen wir mal plan
in die klimapaket verhandlung gegangen
der sollte im verkehr 55 millionen
tonnen co2 bis 2030 einsparen so sechs
bis sieben millionen tonnen durch
digitalisierung
da stand ein ernster pass von home
office also von sohn zu vielen deutschen
designer mark bestimmt bald nur noch zu
hause arbeiten und er hat ernsthaft das
autonome fahren eingepreist wovon die
autobauer aber längst abstand nehmen
der andi zaubert quasi das co2 aus
seiner rechnung aus
genial wirklich um klimaziele zu
erreichen denkt man sich einmal
irgendeinen quatsch aus und schreibt die
passenden zahlen dahinter hier die
neuesten groko ideen das umweltbundesamt
hat nämlich ausgerechnet wenn jeder
bundesbürger pro stunde nur zehn minuten
am stück die luft anhält spart das
garantiert du sagen wir mal 14 millionen
tonnen co2 es kann doch sein oder wer
weiß vielleicht erfindet
forschungsministerin carlitscheck
während sie ein vogelhäuschen bastelt
aus versehen das beamen und wir brauchen
überhaupt keine autos mehr
und was noch teurer ist wir können frau
carlitscheck zurück nach ibbenbüren b
außerdem rettet ein neues high tech
gerät die unbeliebte deutsche bahn ist
schwer zu erklären aber die idee ist
experten erkennen anhand unterschiedlich
langer zeiger wie spät es ist sie nennen
ihre erfindung nur damit können züge
tatsächlich ungefähr zu beklagen
ja
das ist der trend co2 weg durch zauberei
das ist der neue spirit blöd nur dass
klimaforscher gerade alarm schlagen weil
das mit dem temperaturanstieg wohl noch
viel schneller geht als ursprünglich
befürchtet
ich sage wir brauchen radikale ansätze
ich habe früher sehr gerne auch
rinderfilet gemacht wenn man das relativ
problemlos im backofen machen kann und
ich bin vor einigen jahren auch aus
gesundheitsgründen kriegen meine gäste
seither häufiger hähnchen und geflügel
also ich sag mal jeder muss halt im
rahmen seiner möglichkeiten opfer
bringen
auch kentucky fried peter hier noch
hühnchen ja apropos münchen die co2
bilanz der massentierhaltung kommt
übrigens auch sehr kurz vor im
klimapaket er am rande weil die
einsparmöglichkeiten nunmal beschränkt
sein
aha das klimapaket der groko es basiert
also wie wir heute gelernt haben im kern
vor allem auf anreizen kann das
funktionieren
genau dieser frage geht dr carolin
kebekus nehmen an dem heute show labor
für uns nach frau doktor kebekus ist der
mensch in der lage freiwillig das
richtige zu tun dass wir schön aber
dafür können wir aber was anderes nur
der homo sapiens kann von etwas total
überzeugt sein und trotzdem das exakte
gegenteil machen können wir unser
proband hier zum beispiel weiß dass
dieser einer hackfleisch mit salmonellen
verseucht ist
ich hab ihn eben noch mal gesagt und er
mag auch keine salmonellen
aber er mag
aber so sind wir menschen einfach wir
regen uns auf das alle so viel fliegen
während wir auf dem handy eine woche
mallorca für 39 90 buchen
stichwort spieltheorie wenn auch nur die
laizer möglichkeit besteht andere
könnten das problem lösen dann machen
wir selber nix mehr ihr experiment drei
studenten mit ihrem dreckigen wg klo und
die soll jetzt entscheiden wer von ihnen
das endlich freiwillig sauber macht
damit es nicht mehr so stimmt der
versucht euch jetzt seit sechs monaten
man könnte auch sagen das weltklima ist
ein vollgeschoss wg klo von dem wir
deutschen finden dass sollen gefälligst
die chinesen sauber machen weil die doch
viel öfter auf den pott wanja klingt
alles irgendwie hoffnungslos ist ja auch
größtes problem beim klimawandel wir
sollen uns jetzt ändern
obwohl die belohnung nämlich die rettung
der welt erst in jahrzehnten kommt man
soll das also im prinzip für seine
kinder machen und viele leute mögen ihre
kinder halt gar nicht meine welt
damit der deutsche sich ändert muss es
unmittelbare konsequenzen geben so wie
bei diesem experiment unsere testperson
hier möchte die banane essen was er
nicht weiß ich habe die banane unter
strom gesetzt jetzt hat er einen
stromschlag gekriegt bauer also hat er
gelernt banane nicht anfassen
es hat jetzt noch mal ach so klar
natürlich es ist ja jetzt auch ein
männlicher probanden schon mal sein dass
der zweimal
es gibt sogar drk klickt hier für
weitere heute schon videos und clips
moment
und klickt hier um den channel zu
abonnieren
[Musik]